right now i am in montana and we are at
camera camp now this is an event that my
sister and i are putting on with sony
and we've been planning this for over a
year and it just so happens that this
event coincides
with the launch of the new iphone 11 and
the new apple watch series five
so let's do an unboxing and yeah
another unboxing
[Music]
oh
i got interrupts this montage because
this thing looks freaking
awesome look at this oh my goodness
ceramic watch baby we're back together
okay back to the montage
[Music]
we're here with armando and you just
unboxed your phone i feel like this is
like a little gathering like we're all
opening up our new devices and mine
actually is currently still backing up
right now mine's still trying to
transfer from this one and this one we
are out in the middle of nowhere
we're at a ranch the wi-fi is it's fast
but not when you get a ton of youtubers
here one megabyte per second
what is your favorite feature so far
what are you looking forward to testing
um it's gonna sound like the obvious the
cameras
it's great because now you have these
wide angles and
you know these telephoto lenses and it
just it looks so good
i was able to play with it a little bit
and the pictures that you can get
i mean there's a big difference between
the older iphone and this one
i mean you think it's a massive
difference like it's a lot of times it's
like yeah it's
really worth the upgrade no i think if
you're if you love cameras you like
taking pictures or video
it's definitely worth effort for sure i
mean it isn't like a massive upgrade as
far as like specs go
camera-wise like it's a huge difference
and one last thing ios 13 is so much
more polished like i was literally
watching a youtube video and i
didn't even realize this because i
haven't even watched any other videos
about
ios 13. i hit the volume button and you
have a little icon on this
it's like whoa i was 13 is so great yes
midnight screen oh space gray yeah okay
the reflection off the tree right
right looks like wait where's your
midnight green i don't know
oh she has like all the colors okay so
this is it's pretty similar
well especially because it's reflecting
off the trees right so it was kind of
making it look like
i played it safe i mean yeah but the
midnight green
it does look good it was questionable
because you couldn't really tell what it
looked like
in the keynote yeah until you actually
get it and see it
it sounds good
[Music]
look who else i found that has an iphone
11. yes it matches your outfit it does
did you know i dropped this in the
forest playing laser tag
i could literally send you the clip
that's amazing fell out
and i had to use find my iphone and it
was like under grass
iphone come here i lost a forest green
iphone in a forest guys
oh
it's right here i must have lost it when
i was running then
armando had the space gray and
reflecting off the trees his space right
kind of looked midnight green
interesting they are very similar it is
yeah the midnight green was surprisingly
like i
actually really liked this color a lot
yeah me too for my personal photo i went
for the silver
really yeah i mean remember when we were
talking about the ceramic watches
the white silver yeah i've converted i'm
much more i like this yeah i like it
favorite feature is when i'm selfie
videoing mode
it's like a really wide angle yeah
compared i always compare it with the
note 10
um because the note has always have like
high resolution
and a really wide angle for the selfie
camera and i feel like i've been waiting
the thing that you're so crazy about the
note front facing is it would like wash
out your complexion so
yeah much and everything was like super
flat because we just did comparison
i had always compared to those phones
and i think we've arrived
like we have officially arrived where i
don't think people can complain about
the cameras anymore i know the
front-facing 4k
thank you thank you 4k60 have you gotten
some slow fees i was just going to ask
you that was my next question was like
do you want to do a slopey
yes okay yes with the guys because they
don't have long hair so it's kind of
just not as cool let's do it except okay
tyler okay well
we'll stop you next we're like this
we're so cool that might be the best
slopey i've ever seen
to be honest oh my gosh can i get one
for my channel of course
this is how movies are made if you're
wondering all right ready
chasing oh god
[Music]
i made it over a year
oh okay bye
everything is so sad oh my god it's all
my
fault justine this is the best slopey
can i still be your friend or are you
going to do it's my own fault it's my
own fault i've made a mistake
i have drawn two phones
[Music]
hmm
first of all
well it was a slow fee incident
i heard someone screaming they got
murdered i
did i mean it's just like a small little
scuff and honestly i think i could
probably like
um i mean it survived the concrete
yeah i haven't even had it for 15
minutes now you can title this
drop test it didn't shatter i mean it
just dented
i'm sorry it's okay all right anyway
slopes are cool slow fees let's play in
the slow feed
now i have this phone for another year
with its injury it's okay i can run my
camera camp and my phone yeah
it's okay yeah i enjoyed it thanks for
being in my video
i can't believe it no i mean i do
believe it
welcome to coffee chats with justin and
craig here we are going to talk about
the new iphone so you've had it for a
couple of days i've got it how do you
like it so far
i love it i wasn't expecting the quality
to be as good as it is
yeah and i cannot wait to get out and
shoot a hiking video with the video
that's what i'm so excited to do just an
entire shot on iphone
super cinematic really awesome and i'm
shooting some stuff with like the
awesome mobile 3.
this one already has incredible
stabilization but adding that in
i mean it looks like a drone is falling
i don't know what it is but it kind of i
see some shake when i'm shooting it with
my hand but when i watch the video back
it's like always smoother than what i
saw yeah we were surprised how
great the wide angle looks when you're
walking too yeah i'm looking forward to
seeing your
hiking iphone video do you know where
you're gonna want to go spain
spain oh shoot oh that'll be so fun oh
my gosh we'll have fun let us know
what's up yeah
okay cool let's find somebody else who's
got an iphone
[Music]
okay you've had it for three hours now
give or take same and i already dropped
it which is unfortunate
it's okay it happened during a slophy
moment so i feel like it's okay it's
appropriate it is
so in the three hours what do you think
so far and what are you looking forward
to testing the most
okay so first off the back of this
feels so good i did not expect it to
feel as good as it does
um i'm also really liking my choice with
the white because this looks different
doesn't it is there's no
well do you have a different color i'm
never taking this case off again thank
you
you'll never see what the back of this
looks like again yeah so never mind the
thing i said about the back it's fine it
doesn't case would be fine
no i mean the back of it looks really
cool it feels nice it does and it's less
slippery than the previous version
because this is so hard to hold on to
yeah so this that made a huge difference
i like that a lot
of the cameras the thing i want to test
yeah right like i want and i want to do
that thing they did in the demo with the
filmic pro where they were like
four different cameras at once that's
what i mean so awesome yeah i don't
think that is
out yet but it's going to be really cool
because what i want to do
is kind of do like vlogging like i can
vlog myself and vlog
what's around you're seeing in front of
you so it's going to be super cool
yeah i'm excited about it for sure
hi okay okay iphone 11 what do you think
what do you think what do you think yeah
uh i'm kind of i'm kind of busy no
you're not what are you doing we're
talking about
i'm not doing anything are you editing
no i'm not are you ready what are you
watching let me see the movie no no no
no no no no he's totally
fine
i managed to pull him out of his cave of
editing you've been editing non-stop for
the past several days you haven't slept
so so thank you for being here with us
thank you for having me so you've had
the iphone for a couple of days
yes you actually got a bunch of
shipments here today yeah i did
oh my goodness clearly the iphones have
been delivered
what is what's going on i don't
understand what's going on
hello what do you think so far i love it
this keynote doesn't really really
deliver what this phone can do
and when you compare it to the other big
guys you see that they really did
something amazing
the audio zoom they didn't even
demo the audio zoom it it is it is
fantastic
what's crazy is his videos are so
in-depth i mean you basically test
everything i mean you do speed test
battery tests you do
i mean your tests are so intensive like
it is just exhausting to watch because i
know
what goes into doing that so if you guys
want some crazy extensive testing go
check out this channel i'll put a link
in the description because it's going to
be
awesome what do you think of the
wide-angle lens it's pretty cool
wide-angle lens is really good
there's no barrel distortion it doesn't
have the optical image stabilization it
doesn't it's a fixed focus
but still it is really good and the
electronic image stabilization that is
applied to it
is fantastic and it shoots in 4k 60
frames per second
which is a big deal because the other
ones cannot do it dolby atmos is amazing
i i found a way to demo it to you
guys so if you watch my video with
a pair of headphones you will hear the
difference and
i'm sure people are gonna say oh he's
faking it
no no the difference is with each other
you got a leather case on it oh yeah
this is the first time i'm seeing the
leather case i'm nothing without the
leather case that looks good
and i'll tell you a good thing i had my
case on when my mind took a small fall
even though i think it was
okay because this is stronger glass as
it's tradition right
yeah it has to fall you do do drop tests
but i don't even ever do drop tests
they're all
[Music]
accidental
we gotta go chat with jenna we gotta see
what she thinks jenna
yeah let's go ahead and see this girl
this is our cabin oh my gosh no one
should see what's
happening it wasn't one time very nice
and organized
but jenna's got some stuff going on over
here okay so i have three hours until
this restores normally i don't like to
restore from backup but
it has all my stuff the one of the
reasons that i did restore from backup
is because i wanted all my lightroom
photos that was in there and also the
insta360 library i wanted so this is one
of the first times that i've ever
actually
done an entire backup it's not the first
for me but it's not
i usually do it all the time but i
always have um problems but i also have
twenty thousand pictures that i
want that's a lot but i think i also
have like six probably
um so i haven't used it yet but
i like the feel of it it's not as uh
slippery it's kind of slippery
well not as slippery been taking a lot
of photos you've taken so many pictures
of me on mine so
taking pictures of me on my phone what
have you thought so far
i like it i'm really excited for the
night mode
it's really good where am i going to
sleep tonight
on the floor can you sleep on the floor
look at all this room
go see it
[Music]
you got yours and how long have you been
using it um for probably like four hours
okay so in those four hours what have
you tested and what are you most looking
forward to testing i've tested the
cameras
and i have to say that the biggest thing
i noticed is that the ultra wide is
consistent with the other
other cameras yeah and the quality is is
crazy
crazy good hdr is great and the display
is still it's nice and bright and i
tested it with the sun
directly on it and i was still able to
see everything clearly and ios 13 of
course runs very smoothly on the on the
processor so the phone feels great and
it looks great and it matches your
little army green outfit there so good
yeah what do you think of the color so
far do you think it's different
from what you saw online it's it's about
the same yeah and i like it i like that
it's matte and i
like that it's not really super glossy
anything like that so it just shows up
well on camera especially yeah
and i like this camera already it kind
of grew on me you know it looked a
little weird at first
but i actually do like it and it's a
good way to distinguish that you know
you have one of your iphones and i
really like that this is all one piece
of glass
which is kind of cool because i mean it
just makes it all look super seamless
yeah and the fact that apple made the
iphone bigger to compensate for that
bigger battery
i like it i mean i like a phone that
feels like it has some power inside of
it feels like it can actually
you know last all day with the battery
so i mean i kept holding both of them in
both of my hands i'm like i can't feel
the difference
yeah yeah i would like to do like a say
a taste test or not
today we're doing a taste test with the
iphone but just like out of a blindfold
test to see if i can tell which is which
yeah but i guess i'd be able to feel it
i'd probably put a case on
like hold it without yeah you may be
able to but i do love it it's
way easier to hold into yes yes the old
one like it just would fall right a
little bit
yeah my first impressions of that i mean
this phone i think from what i've seen
from a lot of people when you actually
get it and start using it
some people may see it as a super
exciting update but it's a lot of little
changes little things like that inside
of it that i think is going to be
a winner for this year i am excited
obviously
okay we'll have up with your phone
he's been filming this entire video for
me so tyler you've got your phone
what do you think i really like that
it's like in pristine condition
dented or scratched
i'm sorry it's okay the drop that that
phone had it should have shattered like
when i got the pixel before i had
unboxed it and i dropped it like maybe
from like here
the thing shattered completely like this
thing took a massive fall so
it survived yeah so other than your
pristine condition
space gray well everyone's been saying
they like how it feels i like that too
but something
that i need to test more but i don't
think anyone is talking about
oh secrets you might have to get a
close-up okay in
the iphone 10 and in previous
iphone software maybe when i go to
darken a photo
if i want to decrease the exposure in
previous
versions it would really wash out the
whites right
so it would it would make them see how
they're staying bright
yes so that has been do you have a 10 s
i really don't like what the software
camera software has been doing
when i want to underexpose a photo
because i like to underexpose photos
especially when there's like a bright
sky i like to do this and i like to
you know that's like a cool silhouette
look right
but on the 10s it washes out the whites
and doesn't keep them
contrasty like that okay so
find this frame and
tap and then drag down
yeah holy moly it's way different let me
turn my brightness up maybe let me try
mine too okay so my brightness is all
wrapped how does that look jon
oh my god okay so okay boom
see how see how yeah mine is staying
contrasty
whoa so i don't know it might not it
might be
something i'm misinterpreting but no we
just i just noticed at that
and i was like this is different
something is different here with the
camera
something has changed i did notice that
but i didn't
know what was happening yeah so this all
makes sense
yeah so i think the general consensus
is the camera's pretty freaking great
the cameras are
i mean until something else comes out
it's the best
camera in a smartphone so tyler has
helped me shoot the note video the pixel
video so you have been there and you've
seen a lot of this footage up close
i haven't been this excited about an
iphone camera for
like four years so and here we go it's
exciting
look how excited he is he's actually
really excited we have one two three
iphone
yes yes this is the other one's backing
up so it's fine
pretend this is an iphone okay one two
three
i don't know because it's so peaceful
and beautiful out here guys we got to go
i think there's a sunset happening
yeah bye do you want to go okay bye i'm
gonna end my video now thank you guys so
much for watching this is really fun and
thank you to everyone who participated
in this video
and thank you sarah for making me do a
slow fee with you and
possibly breaking my phone but
thankfully
i did not it survived stronger glass is
a thing
i will see you guys soon and make sure
you check out everyone else's channels i
will link them below
bye hey rosie yeah rosie come on
rosie go see the phone rosie oh my gosh
this isn't
oh you are wet hey here you get him
he's so wet hi you wet little diggy
look at that butt go show justine go see
him go show her how wet
you will you show me how wet you are
you're very wet would you like to go
under my umbrella you're super wet
she's soaking wet you can't go in there
honey i tried to get you to come in
earlier not now no
you're s oh my gosh she wants in there
so bad
rosie no no no
hi she's trying to get them no nope
nope this is incredible got you
she got me good she grabbed you bye
rosie it's cause she loves me
[Music]
jesus hey what do you think of the new
iphone
uh the new iphone why don't you guys
come in and let me tell you so about it
i thought you were gonna tell me to go
away